European treaties
which serve 1 small number each time
which is enriched,
especially butter for example
which has
multiplied by 16 its expenditures in lobing activities.
Today
there are 70 lobbyists for 1 member of the European Parliament.
70% of these lobbyists are from tobacco,
the pharmacy,
the automobile.
How can you tell me it's the interests
of the people? I,
my little Marie from the village of Saint-didi
of one thousand two hundred inhabitants in the finister,
I have no weight today except to commit myself,
than to be able to touch their living conditions and
social conditions.
And now it's really more than just acting,
it is really more than that to act because
uh.
Under the pretext
Of legislated duties,
in fact we break,
we break the social conquests,
we break the work code with uh.
The uberization,
we break uh the ecology
and we break the future.